I I think as Magnus used to say you have
to enjoy the process and not focus on
the result too much uh but you know it's
it's it's good you know I mean I I think
I'm just happy to have a career to you
know to play Chef I I I love playing
Chef I enjoy playing the game and know
happy to be alive oh that's such a great
approach I mean many players should
listen to this interview and have it in
mind you know that sometimes if you are
too focused on your goals it can
actually um you can forget about the
process and enjoyment right yeah for
sure I've heard many players who say
that they are their best results when
they have no goals or they have no
expectations but again I don't think it
works with everyone it very much depends
on your personality